bluh hmm hello and welcome into this
video playing warps Washu all right so
c5 yeah d5 is a good line but let's see
how good he is and in a Sicilian I
probably wanted the Sicilian right so
oops
that's rare so he wants to play with 96
and hmm what is the possible drawback of
this whenever something pops up that
never that is never played there is
quite often a problem might be five
probably threatening mate in one
okay and now 96 would be weird if that
isn't an advantage Queen to a5 but what
does that help odd okay so he doesn't
want to get checkmated and therefore
tries to trade Queens
it is not hmm it's not easy actually to
avoid the Queen trade I mean I could try
to stay on that diagonal basically and
keep him from castling but I mean I'm
just better here right if I if I
exchange this is a really good ending
the question is a little bit how do we
continue Bishop before it's better yeah
maybe we should be form
just keep him keep him back and then
castling long
yeah that's okay and now he starts to
think but to some regard it's already
too late its position is very bad now
the question is this really is long
castling really doing me any favors not
so certain okay it's not it's not so
clear if I want to cancel show Castle
queenside because a-four a-five is
something that is generally very useful
in such a situation and I'm going to do
it right away I mean this is a nice nice
position but you have to ask yourself
how progress is going to be made and
a-four a-five is one of the things that
just helped okay well okay not certain
that this is helping him in the long run
Wow
really I check and go a six
that's just winning there was a pretty
disastrous opening okay
yeah rook the one coming coming next
you can hardly move anything really
tough I'm a pizza and black has no moves
okay so let's regroup
okay that was a pretty disastrous
opening um yeah against this move water
there are a couple of good options
the best one objectively is probably d5
but okay neither three is not not a
mistake you can also place III this is
what I recommended in my in my book
actually they keep it simpler 1.e4 book
because this is part of the repertoire
against the Sicilian so and it works
well in this regard okay but I play this
with widened yeah that is probably not
the best choice it's just not a good
what if I do your Hema in the evening
anyway it's not so clear what blacks
move is now if you go a six which would
fit into this I have stuff like Bishop
f4 and you're kind of wonder why black
is playing like this it looks pretty
awkward
yeah ninety-seven I think should be
better for white okay this is some
straightforward and here why does
eternity better has to be the the pair
of bishops is nice and I'm just yeah you
you stop him from canceling so best is
probably the engine suggestion of Queen
e7 but okay white white has a slight
advantage she he went for a slightly
worse version of this ending and now
there are a couple of things that white
can do I also like the move that the
engine is suggesting a for one of the
moves to be ready to meet b6 immediately
with a 5 because b6 looks very likely
now he has a hard time to move the deep
horn that would be also quite awkward
but I think my move is okay as well but
should be formed b6 Bishop d6 I don't
think it's that good actually because he
had f6 and Knight f7 that's a bit better
than 96 but the
fundamental evaluation is not changing
white is going to be going to be
pressing here forever and now a four I
think is a good idea to get concrete
play and you basically develop the book
by that weathered move and yeah this is
just really bad okay that that loses the
house and it wouldn't have been uncalled
for to resign now but he continued a
little bit then yeah here in this
position black you should probably not
take on before that is just a premature
move okay guys thanks for watching